bien en este vídeo vamos a hablar un
poco de cómo fuimos creados lo que vemos
aquí es una foto de un espermatozoide
fusionándose con un óvulo este de aquí
es un espermatozoide déjame ponerle el
nombre
es ver más
soy de mientras que este de aquí es el
óvulo así que lo voy a poner aquí
y esta escena de aquí es el final de una
competencia épica porque este
espermatozoide que acaba de llegar aquí
es uno de 200 a 300 millones de
espermatozoides que están compitiendo
por este óvulo por aquí voy a poner a
uno de ellos se me ocurre ponerlo más o
menos aquí uno de estos 200 o 300
millones este no fue el que ganó en la
competencia por aquí voy a poner a otro
para que veas varios de ellos muy bien
esto lo voy a poner más o menos así y
bueno por acá voy a poner a otro otro de
ellos se va a ver más o menos así
entonces hay de 200 a 300 millones de
espermatozoides y todos ellos compiten
por este óvulo y el espermatozoide que
ves está a punto de fusionarse con el
óvulo es el ganador de esta competencia
increíble date cuenta son cerca de 200
de 200 a 300
millones
ciones es decir que esté en cierto grado
es una gran victoria y todos nos
deberíamos de sentir muy bien con
nosotros mismos somos el producto de
este espermatozoide que tengo aquí que
compitió con cerca de 200 a 300 millones
y ganó la carrera para llegar al óvulo
de nuestra mamá el espermatozoide
proviene de nuestro papá mientras que
este óvulo es de nuestra mamá y todo
esto ocurre dentro de nuestras madres
ahora una vez que pasó todo esto vamos a
hablar un poco acerca de la terminología
en este vídeo lo primero que quiero que
veamos es el proceso donde se funcionan
estos dos el espermatozoide con el óvulo
ya eso se le conoce con el nombre de
fecundación fue un dado
sí o sí
y este proceso produce una célula que da
lugar a todas las células de nuestro
cuerpo como puedes imaginarte este la
fecundación es un proceso muy importante
entonces asegurémonos de que entendemos
bien las distintas palabras para las
diferentes cosas que actúan en este
proceso primero cada una de estas
células sexuales es decir el
espermatozoide y el óvulo se llaman
gametos entonces déjame escribirlo el
espermatozoide
un gato
y el lóbulo también es un gameto así que
lo voy a poner con su respectivo color
me
y cómo vamos a ver cada gameto tiene la
mitad del número de cromosomas que
tienen las células de tu cuerpo o más
bien la mayoría de las células somáticas
de tu cuerpo
entonces las células sexuales éstas que
tengo aquí que están ya sea en sus
ovarios o tus testículos dependiendo si
eres mujer u hombre tienen la mitad del
número de cromosomas y vamos a ver esto
con mayor profundidad para esto hagamos
un aumento de este espermatozoide que
tengo aquí lo voy a dibujar ahora con
este color con color naranja y por aquí
está la cola del espermatozoide tenemos
esta parte así y bueno aquí tenemos a la
cabeza del espermatozoide la voy a poner
más o menos así
no lo estoy dibujando a escala de hecho
puedes darte cuenta que el
espermatozoide es mucho más pequeño que
el óvulo pero nos va a ayudar para dar
esta explicación ahora justo aquí en el
espermatozoide tenemos un núcleo del
espermatozoide que voy a poner justo
aquí este va a ser nuestro núcleo que
tampoco está a escala y si estamos
hablando de un ser humano y bueno estoy
suponiendo que tú eres un ser humano por
lo que esto puede parecerte interesante
en este espermatozoide tendrá 23
cromosomas de tu papá déjame hacerlos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 22 y el cromosoma 23 es el
cromosoma que determina tu sexo es tu
cromosoma sexual si tú tienes aquí en
ese cromosoma número 23 una equis si tu
padre contribuye con una equis entonces
serás mujer y si tu padre contribuye con
un ayer con una yema
entonces serás hombre muy bien estos son
los cromosomas del gameto masculino o
bien podría decir los cromosomas del
gameto con que contribuyó tu papá
el espermatozoide este es un gameto lo
voy a poner así
me tomo y este se va a fusionar con el
ángulo así que ahora voy a pintar aquí
al óvulo y ojo no lo voy a hacer escala
recuerda que lo voy a pintar aquí pero
no está hecho escala lo voy a poner más
o menos así el óvulo es mucho más grande
y también voy a dibujar por aquí el
núcleo del óvulo lo voy a poner más o
menos así el cual tampoco está hecho
escala pero nos va a ayudar a que te
diga que tu mamá también va a contribuir
con 23 cromosomas entonces los voy a
poner 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 20 21 22 y también ella va a
contribuir con un cromosoma que va a
participar en la determinación del sexo
va a ser con un cromosoma
entonces si los cromosomas que
determinan el sexo son equis y serás
hombre y si son x x entonces serás mujer
y bueno este también es un gameto un
gameto femenino así que lo voy a
escribir aquí
por lo tanto gameto es el término
general ya sea cuando nos referimos a un
espermatozoide oa un óvulo ahora una vez
que estos dos se fusionan que tendremos
y para eso voy a bajar un poco en la
pantalla una vez que estos dos se
fusionan entonces que tendremos esta es
la pregunta y bueno lo que tendremos es
un óvulo fecundado y un óvulo fecundado
lo voy a poner más o menos así y con un
nuevo color se me ocurre este nuevo
color para mi óvulo fecundado a este le
vamos a llamar sy goto y recuerda que no
estoy dibujando escala pero lo voy a
poner más o menos así más o menos así
para que tengas una idea clara de lo que
está pasando y voy a dibujar aquí su
núcleo núcleo celular algo más o menos
así lo estoy haciendo lo más grande que
pueda para que nos enfoquemos en los
cromosomas que hay en él y una vez más
nada de esto está dibujado escala
entonces tendrás los 23 pares de
cromosomas de tu papá y los voy a poner
justo por aquí
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21 22 y bueno en este caso
viene un hay en una que te voy a poner
aquí y luego tendrás los 23 cromosomas
de tu mamá así que los voy a poner justo
así 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 21 22 y 23 una equis en
el lugar 23 y como habrás notado los
dibuje en pares y es más déjame ser más
claro tienes 23 cromosomas de tu papá lo
voy a poner justo por aquí 23 cromosomas
creo
son más esto en el caso de tu papá y tu
mamá también' 23 cromosomas 23
cromosomas chrome
soy
más y ahora si tienes 23 cromosomas de
tu papá 23 cromosomas de tu mamá
entonces este cigoto este óvulo
fecundado date cuenta que va a tener el
doble 46 cromosomas en este óvulo
fecundado así que lo voy a escribir aquí
son más y ahora tenemos el conjunto
completo de cromosomas y esta célula
puede seguir replicando se divide en 12
y diferenciándose para crear todo lo que
hace que tú seas tú y justo llamamos a
este de aquí un cigoto déjame escribirlo
este es un sí
y una manera de pensar en todo esto es
que los gametos son células sexuales que
tienen la mitad del número de cromosomas
y el cigoto es la célula que está lista
para diferenciarse en un organismo y que
tienen el conjunto completo de
cromosomas en este caso 46 cromosomas y
como puedes ver los puse en pares y
estos pares los llamamos pares homólogos
cada uno de estos pares cada uno de
estos es un par de cromosomas homólogos
así que déjame escribirlo este de aquí
es un par par de cromosomas cro
son
más cromosomas homólogos
voz y esto qué significa bueno eso
significa que en general estos dos
cromosomas donde uno proviene de tu papá
y el otro de tu mamá codifican para las
mismas cosas codifican para las mismas
proteínas pero distintas variantes en
como codifican estas proteínas y esas
son las características que tienes y
ahora bueno diré una gran simplificación
pero lo puedes ver de esta manera
digamos que este cromosoma que proviene
de tu papá codifica de cierta manera
para un tipo de color de cabello
mientras que bueno esta variante de este
gen en el cromosoma proveniente de tu
mama codifica para otra variante del
color de cabello entonces estos son
cromosomas homólogos los dos en general
codifican para las mismas cosas por lo
tanto ahora podemos decir que tenemos un
cigoto con 46 cromosomas o dicho de otra
manera que tiene 23 pares de cromosomas
homólogos y esto en el caso de los seres
humanos si estuviéramos hablando de
otras especies en lugar de decir 23
pares de cromosomas homólogos
o 46 cromosomas también podemos hablar
de una especie que tenga 10 pares de
cromosomas homólogos o 20 cromosomas
ahora para hablar con mayor claridad
sobre el número de cromosomas de una
especie dada los biólogos usan las
palabras aplauden y diploide y la
palabra aplauden se refiere a cuando
tenemos la mitad del conjunto completo
de cromosomas entonces en este caso para
los humanos el número plate es 23 es 23
estos dos de aquí hablan del número a
floyd en número
pero aplauden
loi
y es justo 23 para otras especies sería
otro número y aplaude tiene su base en
el prefijo aplon el cual significa
sencillo así que podrías pensarlo como
un miembro sencillo de cada uno de estos
pares ahora cuando tienes ambos
cromosomas en cada parte o bien cuando
tienes todo el conjunto de cromosomas
entonces estos 46 cromosomas van a
formar lo que se conoce con el nombre de
número diploide este de aquí va a ser mi
número diploide número diploide de lo
y cuando las personas en general hablan
del número aplaude y nosotros lo
usaremos mucho cuando hablamos en
general de la mitosis y la meiosis se
usa como convención es decir se refiere
al número aplauden como n cromosomas con
la letra n mientras que si hablamos del
número diploide es 2 veces el número
aplauden y por lo tanto lo expresamos
como 2 n 2 n cromosomas en fin espero
que esto ayude a que vayas conociendo
parte del vocabulario relacionado con el
concepto de fecundación y el significado
de palabras como up lloyd en diploide
cigoto y gametos y bueno además espero
que este vídeo te haya servido para
hacerte sentir mucho mejor acerca de ti
mismo y que pienses que solo para
existir al menos la mitad de sus
cromosomas tuvieron que ganar una
carrera increíblemente competitiva